so today's topic one of the things you
also talked about in the book that I
really enjoy is how you teach women to
be proactive and to approach men yeah
100% I think it is that like why would
you not want to be an active participant
imagine but imagine that there is a
world where you wait for the right job
to find you that you're just like
refused it'll come it'll fight it if it
wants me it'll approach me agree because
you would understand a bit more what men
have to go through like it's hard to
approach a woman it's hard you're just
standing here and you just like get no
no no new no like you wouldn't
understand how awkward man Arsen sounds
when they approach you there's a lot of
my friends I like to say that yeah we
should [ __ ] those gender roles and we
need to do better and that don't want to
approach men approach them go ahead yeah
but when I approach them like when I
approach them some of them they got girl
thing on sound means it's for you to
find out yeah but you know they say no
and I mean I feel like I'm interrupting
yeah maybe you are maybe you are
interrupting have that in your cup take
a little sip of that see how it says it
is rough to go out there and talk to a
woman
he won't equality you take the whole
equality cake take it and you eat it you
want to be courted fine but know that
your options are gonna be sometimes
limited if you ugly yes I said that
because it's a fact you want to be
quoted play you don't have the proper
shoes to play the ball Cinderella you
left your slippers at home oh that's
very shallow yes and then you know what
ugly guys do they approach why don't
nobody approach me even the guys that do
approach you like once in a blue moon
when they do approach you they're not
the guys that you want why is it always
the guys that you don't want who are
full of confidence as I I'm flattered
thank you but please you know and I know
you shooting your shot is not actually
gonna school like you're not gonna
school but it was nice it's cute they
approach girl and you know why could be
nobody's gonna miss 99 side
but they know if they shoot a thousand
they're gonna get one in so they keep
bring that math back
you said they know they're gonna miss 99
shots but if they shoot a thousand
they're gonna get one at least cuz
you'll 99 plus one that's a thousand big
old shoots but I always tell people man
two wrongs don't make a right but I'll
do make a double and what I've learned
over time people don't want to try I
think in this dating space they look at
trying as gross like oh you read a book
like you're desperate oh you try like
those cooking classes like oh you're
talking to people you're researching you
like you're needy and gross whereas in
every area in life that you want to get
good at so true you have to research you
go to practice you had enlist the help
of gurus you have to go out there and
try different techniques out and that's
how you develop mastery if you want to
get good at something but in this space
it's like the more you try the like
grosser or worse you probably added it
all right but even even so you know it's
like a lot easier for women to approach
men than it is for men to approach women
to church because when I approach a
woman her defenses are up generally
speaking why because men are you know a
little bit scarier they they might be a
little bit more of a threat I've had
women approach me and my general consent
idea was like what's happening right now
I don't even know I've never been
threatened must be crazy why me you not
me understand that and it's I'll be
honest with you most of the time when
women have approached me to have had the
balls to I've always thought it was very
endearing perceive the moves well yeah
me like it can't go wrong like about
pushing up on you he can't be like okay
chill or you got to get the spines first
thing
yeah you gotta kind of brush them off a
few times before you make the move water
women claim to approach men but what you
find out is their definition of
approaching man as giving the men the
signal is being available at being
available and all and as the approaching
or they wait for the men to make it
clear that the way is open before they
make the appropriate Wow
any girl says hello like that I just
assume they work at Macy's or some
[Music]
a sly
does this video got feldheimer right now
[Music]
and then you call him a jerk when he
didn't catch on the signals you're a
grown-ass woman you've your words
use your words your whole grown-ass
person
use your words oh you look I've
approached him are you doing Jules your
words because I think I think from Owens
perspective they are taking the
initiative by making sure that they look
good that make sure they did their
makeup they did all that stuff and they
went out and then he look cute right
they felt like they've done their part
and now you got to do yours but that's
not the point you just I gotta make sure
I look good too I mean I take showers
and [ __ ] I take showers and [ __ ] you
gotta take showers you know you're doing
makeup the whole eyes their lips
foundation right picking out the perfect
outfits all that good stuff
make a shower and [ __ ] yeah sometimes
guys don't car cuz you're scared of the
rejection back that's good to know
that's good to know what else thank you
what else do we want to know from them
okay we got a question over here
if a girl showing you that you're that
she's interested and yet you have a fear
of rejection I don't get all right let
me let me break it down for you he
offered you his experience his truth and
we challenged it question did what
attitude and you realize that why that's
happening is that a woman wants to have
the benefit of a relationship in and of
intimacy but she doesn't want to put her
self-esteem on the line and so she gives
the man the signals so that he could put
himself in harm's way for her own safety
and security do you understand how crazy
that is
we got to reframe this whole [ __ ] well
that would be like yo you want to
treasure over there but it's
booby-trapped you don't want to do
yourself so you manipulate
somebody else to go and get it for you
and if they die in the process that's
their present you something that really
bothers me and like honestly has given
me a sense of a little bit of an
insecurity is the fact that yeah like
there are all these women like throwing
themselves but me like the past 10 years
like I don't have any of that like I
have zero it sounds weird but like male
attention it didn't work for me
I read like three times I I just said
hey I think you're cute here's my number
I would wait like maybe you're not that
high it's not because you go out there
that's gonna get some did you tried
three times and you gave up three times
what's the most devastating rejection
you ever done with where you approach
somebody man I was in high school so
yeah because you've been single and the
girls I've been with my god but the
girls were mean back then like I got
drinks thrown in my face slaps in the
face were you grabbing people's asses
what were you doing no just hey what's
up girl you want to dance oh hey you got
thinking cute and some y'all ready here
are some of the viewers and they're like
yeah but your your kids back then
yo I've worked in bars like there's not
really that much of a difference between
high school and some of the people out
there in bars like with a way to act in
a witty yeah have you saying have you
had a girl say to you in front of
everybody in the bar while the music is
low between two tracks yeah I've seen
that happy hurts him not calling you
he's doing you a favor for real I don't
even know how many drinks I paid two
guys that just caught a hell wow my G yo
Ellen the next one's on me yo I saw that
this one's on bro sup bro this one's on
me
all right really and he didn't call you
tried it 3000 didn't call you you're
good I understand that sometimes women
get approached so often and so much when
they're out and about that they get fed
up with
that's the reaction so I'm not mad at
that either but I think there's always a
middle ground that you have to reach
between being cruel in asserting your
boundaries
maybe it's like a hard thing for us to
really admit because we're always trying
to find these gender norms and we're
like oh you know men and women we don't
but I I genuinely believe that they like
the idea of not only being approached
but being wooed mmm of course like I've
never had a woman seduce me you never is
you can't seduce me because at the end
of the day when you approach me in my
mind I've already made a decision as to
whether or not I'm willing or whether
I'm open to or not mmm I've never gone
from I'm definitely not interested -
yeah I'll Bank you wise words there's
women who I've made that flip and so
you've made that flip on some woman you
have for sure
I think the long game from I mean yeah I
mean yeah I mean first year no two years
no and then you know three years in we
out and about you know we going for
dinner she's I didn't realize it was so
charming I was at two years of L's make
a W in the third year you know saying as
I did my thing yeah when you play the
long game and you get it in ya was just
something I was thinking like I just
don't think that I think that's why they
don't do it that it also preserves their
ego those are two reasons why they don't
so I'll leave your comments below we
want to know your thoughts what do you
think about this topic
[Music]